what did you do today when rebecca went  to work  nothing just to wake up and drink coffee  i still meet rebecca i watch movie  you're not here like for vacation you're  here this is  it yeah  there's lots of different businesses  that you could actually walk to  to work if you needed to he can't work  right now  day 90 we file for the adjusted visa  for him to be like a illegal immigrant  but right now he's not legally allowed  to work  are you okay with that  i was taking care of myself before he  got here but now you're  responsible for taking care of him  rebecca  and it kind of gets you back into that  whole situation again  i'm not trying to compare you with the x  but there are  similarities  rebecca tell me how it's different it's  a different person he's a different man  both young both from north africa  and now we're at the same apartments  didn't you and your ex live down the  hall  [Music]  what  [Music]  you